et à l'origine donc des jeux olympiques
des jeux paralympiques
bien sûr en angleterre stoke mandeville
et cgo et son intéressant ce qu'à
l'origine c'était un médecin un
neurologue très connu un éminent
neurologue qui s'occupait des personnes
atteintes à la moelle épinière
il était donc paraplégiques ou
tétraplégiques
et donc on est dans l'après-guerre et à
l'après guerre il s'est dit mais il faut
les doter de certaines adaptations ou de
réadaptation grâce aux activités
physiques et sportives
et c'est à partir de là que d'un point
de vue social d'un point de vue
psychique d'un point de vue également
physique il a décidé de pouvoir
travailler sur la réadaptation auprès de
ses patients et il a vu des conséquences
énormes sur leur santé et également sur
leur vie après sociale à partir de là
l'idée de sport c'était au départ une
première activité physique et sportive
c'est le tir à l'arc
ce qui est intéressant dans le tir à
l'arc c'est que ça permet aussi bien une
personne qui est en fauteuil roulant
bien sûr de pouvoir tirer à l'arc à côté
d'une personne qui elle est justement
dites valides et voyez on est déjà dans
l'assise dans le système on va dire de
la mixité sociale petit à petit d'autres
activités physiques ont vu le jour
donc on commence à avoir des jeux
internationaux on va dire à partir de
1948 on est dans l'après guerre
l'après guerre c'est la réparation des
personnes justement aux blessés et dans
cet hôpital militaire à côté de londres
les premiers jeux en 1948 avec bon
nombre de nations qui commence à
agrandir de plus en plus en 1952 puis en
1954 de nouveau des jeux pas encore
appelée bien sûr paralympiques où là il
y avait à peu près je pense 300
participants dont bon nombre de pays
représentés et après il ya eu vraiment
les premiers jeux paralympiques en 1960
et là nous sommes à rome
on ne sait donc externalisée de londres
à rome et voilà un petit peu l'origine
les prémices des jeux paralympiques